they point to the presence of america
in the world's imagination even before
america
was settled
[Music]
so where do we begin this story uh
history always begins in the middle of
things
the western hemisphere in which we
americans live
was inhabited by people who came from
elsewhere
unwilling for the most part to settle
for the conditions in which they were
born
and drawn by the possibility of a new
life of a new chance at life the lure of
freedom
the space to pursue their ambitions in
the way that whatever old world they
came from
did not permit the first settlers came
across
the bering straits from northeastern
asia and filtered down into the settling
the continent
from the yukon down to tierra del fuego
in
south america
we have the evidence of peoples who have
vanished since
they think the maya the aztecs the grand
civilizations that
flourished and flamed out and died
in various ways leaving behind splendid
remnants of their their lives and
livelihood
we see in the north american continent
earthworks and mounds burial mounds
they're somewhat mysterious but that are
the remnants
of what we would call now native or
indigenous peoples
in ordinary american places over the
midwest and the south
[Music]
we see remnants in the west of the cliff
dwelling peoples
the the anasazi or uh use the navajo
name
pueblo peoples who are no longer
there but have left behind these
structures there's something haunting
about this these these civilizations
that were
and have gone um it's haunting too to
think of the earliest explorers
before columbus the leif ericsson who
tried to start a colony on the canadian
what is today the canadian island of
newfoundland
he and other norsemen were
trying their best to establish a
settlement
and then since they are the they could
be called the beginning of american
history but not really they're more like
a false start
on american history and yet they point
to the presence of america
in the world's imagination even before
america
was settled as an idea the presence
of america as an idea a land
of hope a land of refuge a land of
opportunity
of that second chance at life for those
willing to take it it may seem a little
bit fanciful to attribute
that motive to the asiatic the first
asiatic
immigrants to the western hemisphere
they didn't know we don't know anything
about what they were doing they didn't
leave any
any remnants to indicate one way or the
other what they had in mind
we do know that the norris explorers
were motivated by
an impulse to explore to find new lands
and settle them so they were drawn by
something more than just
necessity they were drawn by this
prospect
of a new world of a new start
and this was true a thousand years after
christ
and 500 years before columbus
there was already a mystique about the
west
it was in the literature of antiquity
the ancient greeks
spoke of the isles of the blessed
homer located the elysian fields in the
west
that was where the stream of the world's
seas flowed centuries later thomas
moore's utopia francis bacon its new
atlantis
these are all expressions of the same
theme
the promise of the west
so it's been thought of for a long time
as a land of plenty a land of wealth a
land of hope
of an anticipation of what a new world
could be thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all
of hillsdale college's online courses
they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn